They bring their djembes, their congas and their shakers.
Rhythms build and fade.
Strangers get up to dance.
Crowds gather around.
You can find them each Sunday in Meridian Hill Park in Washington.
It is this circle, the drum circle, that draws them as it has for nearly 50 years...
...when several African-American drummers first gathered.
Willy Posey is one of the originals.
A few guys gathered together, they just started the circle...
...and it just grows, grows, grows, more and more and more over the years.
Abdel Elgizouzi has been coming with his family since moving here from Sudan.
12 years ago, there was a group of about 10, 15 black old males playing.
Now you see, there are almost 150 drummers.
The circle reflects the shifting demographics in Washington.
The US Census Bureau shows that the city's predominantly African-American population...
...has declined five percent since 2000,...
...while the number of whites, Asians and Hispanics has increased 22 percent.
Kevin Lambert says he was the first white person to start playing at the circle.
Several people stopped the drumming when I would show up and say,...
..."You can't play with this white boy."
And this went on for a while and the leader of this finally said,...
..."You cannot pull any racism in this.
This is about music.